(investigative music, camera shot)
- It's like CSI.
We can solve these crime scenes,
only our crime happened
145 million years ago.
You have Allosaurus the predator,
and you have Suuwassea the herbivore.
And they're both found only
yards away from each other.
So there's a story there that
we haven't quite unlocked yet.
(pounding)
(roar)
My name's Jason Poole,
my favorite dinosaur
is probably Ceratosaurus right now.
It's a really cool looking carnivore
with a thing on its nose,
a little horn on its nose.
They’re not like, everybody
else's favorite is T. rex
which is kind of also my
favorite, but I probably have like
five favorites. Silly
question, I love dinosaurs.
145 million years ago, the area was flat,
so every time you had a flooding event,
quite a few animals that would have
just dead across the flat planes.
And every season, the rains would happen,
and it buries everything.
The whole reason that we come
out to Montana and Wyoming
is to find a place that
preserves fossils well.
So a little bit earlier,
one of our volunteers
uncovered this great bone.
You see it's sort of, a little bit
darker than what it's laying in.
In three weeks, we're really trying
to accomplish as much as possible.
So that means we have to get rid of stuff
that's just gonna slow us down.
Paleontology's been done the same way
for the last 150 years.
But data capture has evolved.
Platforms like this allow us
to share this data immediately.
That helps us understand the
areas that we're working on.
- [Voiceover] We got
ourselves a dinosaur.
- That's wicked cool.
(buzzing, intense music)
- [Man] I'll get one more,
and then we're ready to move.
- [Jason] Computers in general just,
it's amazing how much
they speed things up.
You're able to very quickly
adapt to new possibilities.
That’s what we have to be all about.
(intense music)
We work with an awful lot of students,
a lot of young people.
Getting them interested in
science in general is awesome,
being outdoors and doing
science is even awesomer.
- I started working at the
Academy of Natural Sciences
in Philadeplhia when I
was 16, so it's really
Jason's fault that I became a doctor in it
and will continue for the rest of my life.
Fossils are nice, I like fossils.
(intense music)
- [Jason] Technology moves forward,
and it's gonna drag our fossils with it.
Paleontology in general as a science
takes a lot of creativity.
Drawing and painting is sort
of, almost an escape for me.
So it's dealing with my obsession,
which I deal with all day at
work, but in a different way.
It just helps me to
see the bigger picture.
Things start to fall into place,
and you get to these answers and hopefully
those answers just give
you more questions.
Of course most of the clues have been gone
for 65 million years.
That's awesome.
(light piano)